Sudan's top military General is
traveling to Qatar for talks with Amira
Sheikh tamim Ben Hamad al-tani adolfata
al-burhan has left Port Sudan for the
one day visit to discuss bilateral
relations and aid for Sudan but Han has
already visited neighboring South Sudan
and Egypt and is expected to travel to
Saudi Arabia in the coming days
meanwhile earlier Sudan's Army Chief
issued a decree dissolving the rapid
support forces that's the paramilitary
group headed by Mohammed hamdan dagalo
and has been locked in a battle for
control for nearly five months but Han
says the move is a consequence of the
rsf's Rebellion against the state well
we'll get more on that from Heber Morgan
in a moment she's in the Sudanese
Capital Khartoum first let's go live to
Hashem ahabara here in Doha Hashem so
what exactly are we expecting from this
visit to Qatar from budhan
Malia this is quite a significant stop
for burhan uh in Qatar for different
reasons now he will be meeting with the
emissions
and then we're expecting him later in
the day to make a statement before
flying back to Port Sudan just two weeks
ago a group of the freedom forces for
change the civilian component of the
Sudanese Society was here in Doha and
they met with Qatari officials although
the Qatari officials have been saying
that basically they didn't have any
official requests from the Sudanese
government for mediation but they say
that they are open to step in and
provide any kind of assistance for Sudan
this is quite significant also for
al-burhan because this is a moment where
he's trying to portray himself as a
legitimate de facto leader of Sudan at
the same time when we are seeing uh
hemative facing more more restrictions
particularly the latest sanctions by the
United States of America targeting his
brother who is his Deputy at the rapid
support forces and also the decision by
burjan to ban the rsf so this is going
to be a moment for him to ask Qatar for
more political and financial support as
the the conflict gets into an extremely
delicate stage
is expected to go to Saudi Arabia next
what can Gulf countries do at this
moment end the conflict
so since the start of the conflict in
April no one managed to somehow
secure a massive advantage on the ground
for Bohan this could be the moment to go
to the gulf countries which have huge
political leverage in Sudan for two
messages first the need to help him
navigate through this complex political
landscape and give him more support and
when he's asking for support he wants
also strong messages from the Gulf
country saying that they're not going to
be siding with Muhammad hamdan
hemiti his rival and the leader of the
rapid support forces he will be also
asking for more financial support but as
we know Berlin Gulf countries are not on
the same page when it comes to how to
move forward when it comes to Sudan and
also her should be having a bigger say
they will have first of all to in invite
all the political parties to negotiate a
political settlement and the opposition
particularly the forces for change are
saying that there needs to be a reform
of the security forces the Army has to
step aside and pave the way for a
civilian government to take over for the
time being the biggest concern for
al-burhan who is the chairman of The
Sovereign council is his political
survival and the defeat of hemati unless
he gets to that point is going to be
extremely difficult
to negotiate any way out of this crisis
in Sudan okay
there for us Ian Doha you will be
monitoring that visit of General buddhan
into Qatar today let's turn to hibber
Morgan who is live for us in Khartoum
hibber do we know why General budhan has
made this move to dissolve the rapid
support forces now given the Army has
been fighting the rsf since April
well this was a decision that was
expected from the Army Chief and the
head of the sovereignty Council General
abdulfate since the conflict started in
mid-april and it came nearly five months
later now part of the reason why it came
at this time and not at the beginning of
the conflict could be because of how
Regional countries and the International
Community has been dealing with the
rapid support forces at the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs just days ago issued a
statement to the uh African Union uh
committee saying that they are they
should not be receiving members of the
paramilitary rapid support forces
because they were Rebel forced against
the government so the fact that Regional
countries and the International
Community was still re dealing with the
paramilitary rapid support forces as a
legal entity uh established here in
Sudan based on a law could be one of the
reasons why the head of the sovereignty
Council decided to uh disband and
dissolve officially the paramilitary
rapid support forces and nullify the
2017 law that gave it legitimacy and
made it under the control of the our of
the commander or in Chief of the army so
that basically means with that decision
that basically means that the
paramilitary rapid support forces is no
longer part of the organized forces here
in Sudan but rather it's now a militia
that the Army is fighting okay and where
are we in terms of the latest in terms
of the latest fighting in the country I
mean does it appear that any one side
has the upper hand
what we've seen over the past couple of
weeks the paramilitary rapid support
force is launching several attacks
against one of the major one of the
largest army bases in the capital hartum
in the southern part of the capital
Horton trying to take over including on
Wednesday they launched another attack
trying to take over that military base
belonging to the Sudanese Army and we're
not able to do so but we've also seen
more artillery shellings by both sides
against the opposite positions so the
rsf has been launching more artillery
strikes against positions of the
Sudanese Army the Army has been
launching more uh artillery strikes and
airstrikes against the positions of the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
we've also seen an increase in the
number of Civilian casualties just over
the past three days alone more than 50
civilians have lost their lives as a
result of being caught in the crossfire
between the warring sides but nearly
five months on no uh no side whether
it's the rsf or the Sudanese Army has a
very decisive upper hand over the other
for them to claim that they are actually
winning the battle in hartum and in
Sudan thank you for that update hibber
Morgan there for us in cartoon